今天我們來聊一個，你可能沒想到會有這種選擇的案例。
怎麼說？現在不是大家都搶著搭AI的順風車嗎？特別是高學歷的工作者，應該更積極才對。
是啊，所以這個案例才讓我有點詫異。Hacker News 上有一則分享，說一位高學歷的工作者，竟然拒絕去訓練可能取代自己工作的 AI。
等等，拒絕訓練？這跟一般想法完全不同啊。公司花錢請他，他還拒絕？這背後的原因是什麼？
他拒絕的原因很直接，就是怕幫忙訓練AI之後，自己的工作會被取代。他還不完全明白這種不安感從何而來，但那個當下他就是選擇了離開。
所以他是寧願不賺這筆訓練的錢，也不想親手打造一個潛在的競爭者？這很難得，通常人都是先顧眼前利益吧。
沒錯。原文裡就提到，AI 公司會付錢給這些高學歷的專業人士，請他們把多年累積的判斷力教給機器。即便這些系統最終可能取代他們。
喔，所以他是那種，花錢請老師來教機器，結果老師自己失業了，這種局面。難怪會掙扎。
對。他還在思考，把定義我們人格和專業的判斷力交給機器，到底意味著什麼。而且，我們到底在教這些系統什麼樣的判斷？是公平的、善良的，還是符合倫理的？
這就深入了。感覺他不僅是在考慮飯碗，更是在思考AI倫理的問題。那如果我是創業者或主管，從這個案例裡可以學到什麼？
我覺得，很多台灣中小企業主在導入 AI 的時候，常常只考慮技術效益，例如省多少人力、提高多少效率。
是啊，畢竟做生意就是要看 ROI，投入產出比嘛。
但這個案例提醒我們，AI 轉型不只技術部署，更是組織文化和人才管理的巨大挑戰。員工的職涯焦慮是真實存在的。
也就是說，不能只從老闆的角度看，也要從員工的角度看AI導入。
沒錯。如果員工對AI有這種焦慮，卻沒有妥善的溝通和配套，AI導入過程可能會遇到很大阻力，甚至人才流失。
那一般上班族呢？這個概念可以怎麼帶入工作或生活？
我覺得，這個案例提醒我們，在面對新科技時，除了擁抱它，也可以多思考背後的意義。例如，我們的專業裡，有哪些是機器無法輕易取代的「判斷力」？
這種判斷力，大概就是所謂的「軟實力」吧，或者說，那些需要情境理解和人際互動的部分。
是的。就像原文提到，他還在找一份教學生而非教AI的學術工作。這表示他認為人與人之間的傳承，可能跟機器學習還是不一樣。
這樣聽起來，他選擇拒絕，也同時在思考自己未來的定位，以及人到底應該扮演什麼角色。
嗯，這個案例好像也提醒了我們，在追求效率和技術進步的同時，別忘了回頭看看「人」最在乎的是什麼。